un conclure des mois de création de
travail et d'anxiété christian giroux a
suivi les derniers préparatifs de la
collection de popy moreni l'un des
grands noms de la mode française
voici son reportage tu sais mes filles
noires c'est parce que tu crois sont
tout le jour six mois de travail des
idées plein la tête d'un mannequin et
des trésors de patience
c'est ça la préparation d'un défilé jour
en jour c'est fini c'est bien ça a bien
marché c'est toujours bien quand c'est
fait
c'est tellement magique
maman
bien bien bien loin ils préférent jill
impôts bellucci la sonnette petit à
petit comme une tarte à la crème on
corrige en arrange on ajoute du sucre
pas des chiffres et on a on a parfois
des merveilleuse surprise et parfois des
choses qui s'élimine jusqu'au jour où on
arrive à terminer ce travail qui va s'il
va être une grande collection c'est à
peu près 500 pièces 500 vêtements qui
défilent au carré du louvre pendant 30
minutes
tp mois nous on est prêts on attend
là
n'oublions mètres bien moi à nos nerfs
v ribes et man je vais faire pour la
prochaine collection dans la nuit et
j'ai envie de me faire